depuis hier le groupe leclerc fait la
promotion d'une baguette a pris bloqué
pendant quatre mois au nom selon eux de
la défense du pouvoir d'achat des
français ce prix fait bondir toute la
chaîne de fabrication des boulangers
aumeunier en passant par la fnsea le
principal syndicat agricole j'espère que
les consommateurs ne l'achèteront pas
non plus michel edouard leclerc ils
devaient gagner beaucoup d'argent
imaginer sa marge là il s'est révélé
comme un grand qui se fait un pognon de
dengue sur la baguette une polémique à
l'heure où le prix moyen de la baguette
ne cesse d'augmenter selon l'insee il
s'élève désormais à 90 centimes bien
loin d'une baguette à prix cassés à 29
centimes franchement
alors
oui faut-il interdire la vague est à 29
centimes sur webdopoker on vous demande
pas grand-chose dans l'émission fait le
cher si chichement je suis même pas
choquer je suis blessée parce que l'on
pourquoi au petit boulanger qui se lève
à 3h du matin à l'agriculteur qui
produit son blé qui coûte de plus en
plus cher pour après faire la farine ils
sont morts avec ça 9 centimes c'est un
coup de com ça va entraîner la mort
sociale d'agriculteurs qui sont déjà en
péril le petit boulanger je trouve que
parfois le leclerc a de bonnes idées
mais là franchement c'est trop violent
et surtout cette farine on peut pas
lutter en france elle va venir de
l'étranger doué saison que la production
française va être foutu à cause d'un
coup marketing je suis blessée par
israël y en a qu'un qui dénonce et
benjamin juste tellement le rire ça fait
40 ans qui se bat pour les consommateurs
ça fait 40 ans qu'il fait en sorte que
les gens puissent payer moins cher entre
lula et et celui là c'est un coup
marketing mais honnêtement ça
n'empêchera pas les gens de chez le
boulanger acheter une baguette normale
et s'attaquer qu'à des gens d'acheter
une baguette moins cher excuses et ainsi
réduit beaucoup pensé mais arrêter leur
donna beaucoup ne compte plus donc on ne
fait jamais rien ne rentre jamais rien
effectivement donc on voit là un bon
vent on vend la viande moins cher et on
se fait engueuler parce que non
bouteille moi je pense sincèrement que
ce monsieur pour l'économie je le
connais un peu une vraie passion pour
pour moi il a beaucoup fait pour aider
les gens et on peut pas lui faire un
procès pour une baguette il ya des gens
qui peuvent pas payer mais c'est des
gens qui peut pas payer une baguette
c'est un euro un fonds pourrait pas les
payer 29 centimes en quoi ça j'aime
c'est un faux calcul en fait parce que
des belges est toujours à côté de nous
et capte encore faim une vraie baguette
de boulanger au blé complet et c'est une
tradition tel cancel affaires du monde
la moitié n'a plus faim car satan manche
train c'est vraiment 4 d2 comme disait
me jean pierre coffe c'est de la merde
c'est vrai
jean pierre coffe la mefa c'est grave ce
qu'ils ont fait est ce que déjà c'est
pas loyal ça tue le marché et puis c'est
un manque de respect pour tous les
métiers qui sont dans ce secteur-là et
surtout on habitue les gens à ne rien
payer à dire que ça ça vaut rien alors
que ça ne vaut pas rien tout ça pour de
la com et du business parce que c'est
pas bien du tout ça l'irrité aussi
quitter papa mais il est d'abord parce
que je me demande sur quels produits
vont compenser l'a77 baisse où est-ce
qu'ils vont acheter leur farine comme
l'a dit gilles on sait que le blé a
augmenté d'environ 30% donc qu'est ce
que toutes les matières premières
matières premières donc quand il est
vrai que cette farine cette baguette et
je vois pas pourquoi parce que on a peu
de moyens on se souvient de manger de la
merde pardon est directement ça va être
sebha savait donc les gens qui n'ont pas
vraiment les moyens on leur propose une
baguette et on leur dit vous savez quoi
cette baguette elle est pas génial mais
avec à 30 centimes et c'est juste c'est
suffisant car vous avec un zach parisé
dans l'obésité
non non ça tombe à excédents maintenant
alors je vous dire je vous dis regardez
sms une famille peut acheter trois
baguettes pour ces gosses plutôt qu'une
ben désolé mais quand t'as pas de thunes
tu cherches chaussures et
oui c'est ça c'est quand t'as pas de
thunes tu cherches pas aller à la
baguette à 1 euro après ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que leclerc lui il a sa
puissance donc il va acheter anton et
entonne il va sûrement faire venir de la
farine de l'étranger donc le boulanger
français qui pour qui vont lui sa
baguette à 1 euro s'il est dans une
grande ville sur une baguette à un euro
il va lui reste entre 9 et 12 centimes
pas plus et si la campagne peut-être 15
centimes la leclerc ce qui fait il se
perd il se paie une pub leclerc comme il
dit la baguette à 29 centimes alesi moi
je comprends les gens si l'on patine
qu'ils aillent acheter trois baguettes à
29 centimes mais c'est ce qu'a dit le
monsieur la halle et des baguettes même
sam est allé dégueulasse tu peux faire
la série
le niveau d'alerté 1 euro c'est un
connard
élaborer des plans c'est que les mecs
qui font des choses pour l'économiste
captain jack is enough mais ça c'est la
communication de la coop et masques à
20h moi c'est dommage qu'on ait paru
très sioniste et expliquerait que c'est
moi je sais pas s'ils arrivent à vendre
et moissac toutes les baguettes vous
connaissez les prévenus richard et
enfin
l'été premier dans la gueule et pour
plein de choses et la criée et tout ce
qui est fait pour aider les gens vous
faisaient ce qu'ils aient été m'excuser
mais en plus puissent leclerc a dit je
n'ai pas d'argent sous la baguette a
donné quitus au clair et on ne fera pas
de cette excellente 6e fait 40 ans que
jamais de sa grand mère et je te dire
quelque chose alors peut-être qu'il y
est il existe peut-être qu'ils gagnent
pas d'argent soit vrai et ça fait venir
les gens mais oui
ce
que ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'effectivement à 20h - 5 le problème
c'est que tous les petits pains les pain
et les viennoiseries après les
supermarchés les jette donc d'un côté
vous casser toute la filière et de
l'autre côté vous ne redistribuez pas
rejeter si
sarkozy d'abord il nous faut leclerc en
plus ils donnent énormément
surtout la réponse a pour les personnes
qui n'ont pas beaucoup de moyens et à
côté de ça on y jette à la poubelle
alors qu'ils pourraient redistribuer
donc je suis désolé savoura match de la
mort qui est très grave c'est qu'il
allait s'entendre avec cette baguette
que le du coup la baguette à 1 euro en
réalité très cher et que les bons gestes
se font
dessus et qu'ils volent les gens
regardent les gens disent en fait une
baguette à vos 30 centimes en avant un
euro faut savoir qu'un boulanger ça
gagne en moyenne 1200 balle par mois
alors arrêtez de penser qu'ils sont en
train de voler tous les mois c'est pas
du tout le cas donc ça ça mais je vais
vous dire il ya quelqu'un qui m'envoient
par mois ça peut faire un excellent ben
oui
chers mandat je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous ses messageries non
20 euros c'est du budget d'accord c'est
normal oui bien sûr ça ne me gênait pas
par exemple quand c'était sur l'essence
à prix cassés à ce que l'essence est
dans la voiture mais la syrie seul
problème c'est qu'on va faire croire aux
gens effectivement qu'on peut acheter
trois baguettes au lieu d'une qu'on peut
enfin manger beaucoup
et laissez moi finir benjamin le seul
problème cyril c'est que ce pas
objectivement on est sûr qu'il sera pas
bon pas de qualité avec de la mauvaise
farina vrai mais on sait rien il vous
dit on c'est sûr mais ça c'est si mal
automatique ce que je sais c'est bien
surtout si j'entends pas mais vous avez
raison l'un sur 20 euros ce n'est pas
rien c'est clair c'est sur
wii et wii ses robes celle là ça va
venir de nos mails
moi je vous fais oui oui je vous fait le
relais de ce qu'on en voit également sur
les réseaux puisque moi ya plein de gens
qui disent nous malheureusement
9 centimes et prendre ta voiture il a
cramé 29 centimes est cramé du carburant
va à pied chez son boulanger
vraiment on est pauvre c'est ça tombe un
excédent et même manger ma banane en
clair qui est lumière certaines fois il
n'a pas fait une baguette de qualité
avec quelques temps c'était
la belgique baguette on bat les goûters
de
5 ou de porsche et le club est bien
évidemment que c'est une sorte de
liberati de libéralisme sauvage mais
malgré tout il faut quand même penser
aux gens de sortir un peu de nous
libérer de notre de notre paris intra
muros effectivement contre lui par les
nombreuses qu'on a un petit budget exane
achète cinq baguettes et ben voilà ça
fait à peu près un euro verrait cinq
vagues atteignant dix ans il y aura plus
que des lidl des leclerc il s'est tu dis
des bêtises n'est pas vrai at il tonné
me dire c'est qu'il ya un principe de
réalité merci à ce moment là on est il
faut pas acheter les trucs qui sont
fabriqués en chine où sont pas des
journalistes
vous me nommez moi là il faut tous se
remettre encore il faut tout ce qu on se
déshabille ça j'ai fait une coupure
laurent renault et ont fabriqué en
france c'est gilbert l'être autant se
défend le petit commerce matthieu vous
pouvez pas dire m'a l'air dédaigneux y
aura plus d l'idole et des leclerc bas
parce que dans les faits dans ces
surfaces ne pas dire sa race et cette
phase là rien lidl moi j'en ai à côté de
chez moi alors j'y vais les ballots
l'inutile gspc métier que c'est ma fille
m'a sauvé les juifs il m'a dit sa
surface est boudée jusqu'à
jeudi mais n'ont pas ce que j'ai dit aux
concurrents bell a réussi parce que
c'était là me rappelle quand même je
rappelle qu'à un petit bloc ça pendant
six mois et bien moi c'est fini on
guette elle revient oui c'est ça donc on
pense et moi tant que ça